i've got an aunt and uncle and they're  in silicon valley and my uncle's been at  apple and intel and everything and they  raised their kids without electronics  for a while but for long enough that it  actually i think probably was a negative  because all the other kids knew what  they were doing so it's not like you can  isolate your kids from technology  without alienating them we're not  getting rid of technology unless you  want to alienate your kids it looks like  we're becoming more and more isolated  yeah community is a foundational element  if we're looking at ourselves we need  community it's foundational to our  existence that we're meant to be in  community